they are powerful right and they don't
have to be submissive information not
about submission
but being feminine is is following so so
because men lead typically throughout
all of human history men have led and
women follow and men can't lead if
there's no one following you can't lead
when there's no one following at the end
at the end of the day somebody has to
lead a relationship someone has to do it
you can't both lead yeah so when at the
end of the day when there's a decision
someone has to make it if you guys
disagree so part of femininity is
following the man I would argue that
that's in the Patriots society that
we've built which I'm not saying is
wrong but I'm not I'm also saying that
it's not unreasonable to for assume that
the woman can lead as well
lead together biological mention and a
female sports
people like Leo Thomas maybe they should
make well it's a new thing isn't it we
haven't tried it before so maybe we'll
make a new category for people who don't
fall within those categories
if they're a woman that's a question to
ask was specific should biological men
enter female sports no I don't think so
and I would agree with that but I think
it's because obviously um you know why
why if they're women because remember
you said that a man can actually be a
woman so if you don't think biological
men can enter female sports You Are by
default saying that you don't think
they're actually the same they're not
females that one context is a big fat
anomaly in this debate yes
and there's a gender and then there's
biological difference right so if you're
a sport and you've changed your gender
you still probably be a lot bigger like
taller whatever but also coming back to
the submissive Point
um
because I wanted to get that in there I
think today like submissive is seen as a
negative thing and women have to be
powerful and strong and like what's
wrong with being submissive I think
there's nothing wrong with being
submissive and I think you know I think
yeah
in today's society Like You Have To Be
Your Own Boss and you have to be a boss
lady like maybe maybe I don't want to be
a boss yeah if no one is submissive then
certain missions just won't be
accomplished
there is space for people to be
submissive of course there is but
there's also space for people to lead
together it doesn't have to be the term
that woman should be submissive and
meant to take this lady together that
sounds great ideally but when it comes
to practicality it doesn't work you can
cooperate it doesn't work I mean
thank you all right we'll get back to it
it's a case of utility and functionality
and what actually works as opposed to
what we romanticize and idealize yeah
does anyone really lead in today's
society though like we're all being led
like there's no men that are leading
women it's all we're all being led by
there's always and that is not to say
that your job if you're not a manager if
you're a bit lower is isn't as important
it's so important but you need a leader
in a business for the business to run
relations with that organization you've
got nothing really you could be the most
skilled thing yeah we're talking about
relationships they're not because
I think there is a level of like there
is it is kind of a business like you
have to run a house you have to pay rent
you have to make sure the food's cooked
like it is you have to organize things
like the same way you would a business
so you need to have a head and a deputy
head or something like that maybe two
maybe a partner at the top but this is
this is what but this is this is what
feminism lies they say you can have
everything you can't have everything you
can't you can't have it all it's about
sacrifices it's about choices and
trade-offs life's about sacrifice one
thing I want to add is the girls said
that um having feminine men isn't really
a problem in society and I want to kind
of counteract that and say that issues
that you would have with feminine men is
they can't control their emotions like
women can we all know that women are
very good when it comes to emotional
control in in Con in most in general I'm
sorry in general we're using
generalities however you'll find that if
men can't control their emotions they
become irrational if a man becomes
irrational you could find himself
lashing out men are physically stronger
than women in general so an emotional
man you'll find if he's unable to
control his emotion because he's in his
feminine yeah and not in his masculine
where he knows he has to think 10 steps
ahead to make the right decision being a
feminine he's in his emotions men are
not used to you controlling their
emotions you might find he'll lash out
and do things that are not conducive to
a good relationship but controlling and
regulating your choice if you want to
regulate your behavior that is your
choice obviously a lot everyone lashes
out from time to time but people have
limits people know what their limits are
what they're willing will not do if
you're a man and you can't control your
temper you can't blame it on the
femininity you need to sort yourself out
the difference between a man lashing now
and a woman lashing out is if a woman is
out and hits a man not not much could
happen in most scenarios but if a man
lashes out and hits a woman there's a
possibility that if he in his rage can't
control his power he could kill her and
honestly when I go out and I'm doing
Street interviews I'm not afraid of men
I'm afraid of women every time every
time I've been threatened by someone it
is a hundred percent but a woman it's
never happened to me okay in context of
both regulating controlling your
emotions is a learned behavior right
it's a sophisticated learned behavior
women don't always have the ability to
regulate their emotions they have to
learn that men can do the same it's not
impossible it's a learned behavior right
and and it might be have a greater
intensity short but they probably also
have like the same capacity to be able
to pull that back women have intense
emotions you know they lash out and
react differently but that intensity is
still there and we're controlling that
and regulating that is 100 learned some
people learn it early on with the you
know parent figures parental figures can
teach them that some people have to
learn it later on but essentially it's a
learned behavior like especially if you
feel intensely no one comes in this
world able to navigate their emotions
and experiences it's confusing but the
thing is there's consequences for men
there's not for women there's that's
that's the whole thing you know because
like look at what happened with Johnny
Depp and Amber Heard she still hasn't
even been convicted that's the crazy
thing she did all that like it's just a
civil suit it's not even from if that if
it was vice versa Johnny Depp would be
in jail if that happened to a man with
power privilege and money
what happens to the average guy and if
you look at um
abusive relationships where both people
where it's one-sided meaning one side's
hitting and the other side is not the
majority of those are women hitting men
it's 70 percent
an emotional men have a high probability
of ending up in prison for good reasons
physical abuse is very high within
lesbian relationships also yeah so then
I would agree the issue is still like
learning how to regulate and control
your behaviors and it's not restricted
to either
who's lashing out but then you're
talking about women who are physically
lashing out isn't the issue the same on
both sides or they're just not
regulating their behaviors so I agree
with your point that the only thing I
want to add to that sorry I need to use
my camera because we've just bought it
you know
yeah shout out shout out I agree with
you the only thing that we are genuinely
trying to say is that there are
consequences or the consequences are far
greater for a man who does the same
thing as a woman yeah in these
situations I would say that there are
situations where like if you was to hit
me people will look and go uh not a
problem if I hit you back in retaliation
I could get rushed yep
I was in shortage one time one girl
tried to show me a um a move that um she
had learned so she put my hand like that
I went I laughed I had five guys
surround me in case I reacted and I was
like wait a minute so how did